news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so nancy pelosi democratic speaker of
the house went on cnn she was
interviewed by wolf blitzer
it didn't go very well and she's
correctly understandably taking some
heat
for how this all went down so let's look
at it i have some thoughts let's get
right
right into the first clip first off
wolfblitzer asks why won't you accept
the republican proposal for coronavirus
relief
and nancy pelosi says it's a bad deal
for the people as you know there are
americans
who are being evicted from their homes
they can't pay the rent
many americans are waiting in food lines
for the first time
in their lives can you look them in the
eye madam speaker and explain
why you don't want to accept the
president's latest stimulus offer
well because thank you very much wolfin
i
hope you'll ask the same question of the
republicans about why they don't really
want to meet the needs of the american
people
but let me say to those people because
all of my colleagues
we represent these people i have for
over 30 years
represented my constituents i know what
their needs
are i listen to them and their needs are
not addressed
in the president's proposal so when you
say
to me why don't you accept theirs why
don't they accept
ours so this is okay so far but then it
starts to get heated as wolf blitzer
pushes back and nancy pelosi
goes after wolff and his colleagues
and this is where it started to not not
be so good excuse me for interrupting
let's go back madame speaker but
they really need the money right now uh
and even members of the i haven't
seen that but but even members of your
own questions
even the members of your own caucus
madam speaker uh
want to accept this deal 1.8 trillion
dollars congressman roe connor
for example let me just let me just
quote roe connor a man you know well
i assume you admire him he's a democrat
and he just said this he said people in
need can't wait
until february 1.8 trillion dollars
is significant and more than twice the
obama stimulus
make a deal put the ball in mcconnell
court so what do you say to roconna
what i say to you is i don't know why
you're always an apologist
and many of your colleagues apologists
for the republican position
rokhana that's nice that isn't what
we're going to do and nobody's waiting
till february
i want this very much now so
now nancy pelosi is starting to get
agitated with
wolf blitzer and he's asking completely
fair questions thus far
the problem here is not wolf blitzer
he's being a journalist and here wolf
blitzer tries again
and that's precisely why
why they're so important right now
yesterday i spoke to andrew yang
who says the same thing it's not
everything you want but you know
there's a lot there honest to god
you really uh i can't get over it
because andrew yang he's lovely yo khan
rokhana he's lovely they are not
negotiating
this situation they have no idea of the
particulars
they have no idea of what the language
is here i didn't come over here to have
so you're the apologist for the obama
and excuse me
god forbid madam speaker i'm asking you
serious questions because so many people
are in desperate news
right now so now nancy pelosi starts to
get flustered
and i think that basically everybody's
being sort of unfair
in their reactions here it is absolutely
true that wolf blitzer is doing nothing
wrong he's asking questions he's asking
reasonable questions
questions we all deserve answers to
which essentially are
if you want coronavirus relief and trump
is willing to do something on it
why wouldn't you just take it and nancy
pelosi has to explain that she has to
that that's
that's fair that's completely reasonable
yes nancy pelosi is wrong to go after
wolfe and cnn because he's just asking
questions and reasonable ones and
attacking
the the journalist is a very bad look
but in addition to that without
defending nancy pelosi
she's dealing with a lunatic in donald
trump in trying to get this coronavirus
stimulus done
and that frustration is clearly coming
through here now her most astute
statement uh there is that neither yang
nor rokhana are negotiating this with
trump
and it has to be insane to be
negotiating this with trump
so i sympathize with her for that but
ex letting the uh frustration boil over
on wolf blitzer as if he's asking bad
questions is a terrible look and wolf
comes back in with more questions
let me ask you this when was the last
time let me respond to you let me ask
you when was the last time
speaker when was the last time you spoke
with the president about this
i don't speak the president's speech
why not call him and say mr president
let's work out a deal it's not going to
be everything you want
not going to be everything i want but
there are so many americans right now
who are in desperate need let's make a
deal
what makes me amused if it weren't so
sad
is how you all think that you know more
about the suffering of the american
people
than those of us who are elected by them
to represent them
at that table it is unfortunate that we
do not have shared values
with this white house and that they have
in their bill
why don't you talk about in their bill a
tax break for the wealthiest families in
the country
while they cut out the earned income tax
credit for the poorest families in our
country
and the poorest children in our country
so again
nancy pelosi saying it's wolf who has no
idea
it's not his job to have an idea here
wolf is there as a journalist to ask
questions like if trump's okay with 1.8
trillion
why won't you take it and get money to
people that's
fair and there are reasonable people on
the left asking that exact same question
and pelosi could tackle that without
attacking wolf blitzer
it's a mistake she's making a mistake i
get the frustration
and the frustration grows in this next
clip
it will be wretched here's what you
wrote in a letter to house democrats
madam speaker and i ask these questions
only as you know
so many millions of americans are
suffering from well you know two people
who know nothing about the agreement
well there is no agreement but what the
suggestions
are as if there's some authority on the
subject
please give equal weight to 12 to all of
the chairman on the committee
who have written this but so many of
your fellow democrats in the house they
want a deal
right now the problem solvers they all
want a deal
right now and here's what they're
complaining about because you wrote a
letter to house democrats and you said
this let me read
a line from the letter you wrote the
president only wants his name on a check
to go out before election day
and for the market to go up is that what
this is all about
not allow the president to take credit
if there's a deal that will help
millions of americans
right now he's not that important but
let me say this
with all due respect with all due
respect and you know we've known each
other a long time
you really don't know what you're
talking about if the plural of anecdote
is not data
yes there's some people who said this or
that overwhelmingly
my caucus wants what is right for the
american people
overwhelmingly our chairman who wrote
the bill read their statements
they all put out their own statements
when they saw what the
white house was proposing so this was
bad
that this is very very bad i understand
why pelosi's fuse is running short
but this is like when the trump people
are sent out to defend trump
and they get frustrated because trump
lies all the time and then they have to
defend trump's lies
on media in media interviews and they
end up attacking the interviewer
when the trump defenders do it it's
wrong and when nancy pelosi does it it's
wrong and it's a bad look
so this did go horribly wrong but not
because pelosi was frustrated
she should have pushed the frustration
on to trump and republicans and she
should have said listen wolf
you're doing your job and you're asking
reasonable questions which the american
people deserve answers to
understand what's going on trump says
he'll sign off on money so why hasn't it
been
been done very reasonable but understand
the impossible position i'm
in where trump tells me no deal via
twitter via twitter last week trump says
no deal stop negotiating
then he goes to a rally and says get
people money the democrats won't i say
i'm i'm for money the democrats aren't
mitch mcconnell says no more deals mitch
mcconnell has been saying for months
we're not doing any more stimulus
understand the bipolar nature of the
situation and then i'm thrown into it so
your questions of me are fair but
recognize the insanity but when she goes
off on wolf it backfires completely
it makes her an unsympathetic character
and now she has to deal with the fallout
from this interview so wolf
blitzer did nothing wrong it's nancy
pelosi who was in the wrong
understanding her frustration with the
completely manic
bipolar insanity of trying to negotiate
this with a donald trump
who says something different every two
hours on twitter at a rally so on and so
forth
that's essentially my my take on the way
this went down